hello everyone
we are at the end of another year
2021
i hope this year have been
[Music]
as meaningful and wonderful as possible
it's been a hard year of course for many
of us as was 2020 and
i'm of course hoping that 2022 will be
easier
in terms of all the things that have
been going on in the world
but here at let's talk religion there's
no denying that it has been probably the
craziest year
ever
i started this channel back in 2018.
well started to do more
regular videos back in the beginning of
2020 so about two years ago but this
year in particular has been incredibly
crazy in terms of the growth of this
channel when we
began the year in january 2021
we were at around
a little more than 50 000 subscribers
and as of me speaking right now we're
pretty close to 300 000 that means that
we have
increased in almost 250 000
in just a year's time which is just
insane to me
i don't understand
why you seem so interested in listening
to what i have to say but i am very
thankful and it makes me hopeful
that the content that i and many other
creators
at the moment are providing you with
something that has been severely lacking
on youtube and on well on the internet
generally which is trustworthy
information
and content about things relating to
religion and
philosophy and or history and these
kinds of things i've really seen in the
last few years
an incredibly
wonderful increase in good material
about this kind of stuff a lot of the
people that i have been
collaborating with and working with
these this last year and and a little
more
are some examples of those kinds of
creators so i think i do some really
great stuff because truly previously and
still
right now i think
in terms of the information on religion
on the internet and on youtube is really
atrocious right it's
either
well it's all really polemical it's
either people criticizing religion
without much knowledge about
religion
from a scholarly perspective and the
same goes for
the other opposite of the spectrum which
is really polemical
channels by practitioners of different
religions who try to
discredit other religions or other
you know sects within their religion etc
it's all about presenting a particular
world view and claiming that that is the
truth or it's about criticizing without
much background knowledge
and a lot of it's just plainly wrong
also there's a lot of
information that comes from dubious
sources that are not academic that are
not scholarly
and so i think what i wanted to do with
this channel was to
increase religious literacy to provide
information provide content that was
trustworthy that was based in academic
research and scholarly
journals and books etc so the quality of
the content on youtube on these topics
could be at least a little better and
the fact that we have
grown so much in the last year gives me
a hope that a lot of you in the audience
are looking for that as well
and that makes me so thankful i can't
express
just how grateful i am that all of you
keep coming that you keep watching my
videos that you keep
engaged in
the comment section some of you are
engaged in
discussions with me on our patreon page
for example it is really wonderful to
see so many people that are engaged and
interested in discussing these these
matters and that i am so so proud to see
that this community
by and large is an incredibly open
community that really discusses and
debates these things from a perspective
that is
so healthy and and just wonderful in so
many ways so i'm really proud of what we
have created here over the last year and
beyond
and i'm really looking forward to seeing
this channel grow in the future as well
um
this video is really just a way of me
or a way for me to say happy new year
to wish you a
meaningful 2022
but also primarily to
say thank you to everyone as i have
done to say thank you to everyone who
keeps watching everyone who comments
everyone who subscribes
and in particular of course a huge thank
you to all of my patrons over on the
patreon page
your monetary support really makes so
much difference and i cannot stress that
enough
really without your support i wouldn't
be able to do what i am doing currently
it's helping me in so many ways
and i'm
so thankful for all of the discussions
and the support in general that i
received from my patrons so to my
patreon community i love you so much
none of this would be possible without
you
and uh i am honored that you have chosen
to support me and my work on this
channel i truly am thank you so so much
i would also like of course to extend a
thank you to all of the wonderful
creators that i have the honor of
working together with over the last year
some of the
most
humble and wonderful people
that i think i've ever met and some of
the most talented people
that i know that are
also doing wonderful work to create a
more
um
a more informed platform and
and and
community here on youtube i'm talking of
course about people like siawish from
almo
like dr justin sledge from the channel
esoterica the channel hikma history
angela puka from angela symposium andrew
henry from religion for breakfast
um
zevi from seekers of unity it's been a
pleasure to work with all of you over
the last year you really
inspire me with your talent and the
content that you make and it's truly an
honor for me to be able to work together
with you um
the success of the channel is also in a
large part thanks to you guys thank you
so much
now that we have
sort of looked back over the last year
it's also a time i think to look forward
to see what is coming in 2022 i will not
be going anywhere at least i don't plan
to uh i will keep making content the way
that i have the last year we have
explored some truly fascinating stuff
we've been exploring music we've talked
about uh sufism we've talked about
things like hermeticism we've gone into
some
christian mysticism as well
we've explored some more of the indian
religious traditions like vedanta and
shankar advaita vedanta
and we even managed to get into some of
the occult sciences back in october
which has all been so so exciting
and for the future i plan on creating
more content just like that
i will begin the year this
weekend
which will be probably on sunday when
i'm recording this will be the first
video of the year which is very exciting
it's a it's a big video about sikhism
it's going to be called what is sikhism
uh i've been looking forward to making
that video for a long time and a lot of
you have been asking for it so that's
finally coming and i'm very excited
about that i want to keep exploring more
of the occult sciences i have a few
really exciting
collaborations planned
for that in particular which i am truly
excited for as well so that's one thing
and then i've also really been wanting
to do some more documentary style
footage
because of the pandemic that's not been
possible for a while obviously
i was planning to go on some trips
this
by like at the end of this year in
december
there were plans to go to jerusalem
there were plans to go to morocco but of
course because of the pandemic and the
fact that it's increased again that had
to be postponed but i'm
hoping that i'll be able to do some
traveling in 2022 and gather some
material and do some more documentary
style videos too to really increase the
production value of this channel in that
way and another announcement is
something that's going to be really fun
and that is that i am actually i'm
finally doing a let's talk religion
podcast so i know a lot of you have been
asking for a podcast and so we're we're
finally doing it uh it's
to begin with it's primarily primarily
just going to be an audio version of
this channel so i'll be converting the
videos that i've made my entire library
or most of it at least into audio form
and releasing that as a as a podcast
but hopefully we will do some exclusive
stuff in audio form there as well
eventually
my wife is actually helping me
do that podcast so she's relieving me of
some of that works that i can focus on
new videos and all the projects that i'm
doing and she she actually works as a
sound engineer so that's that's
wonderful she's really talented and
that's going to be that's going to be
wonderful so you can look forward to the
let's talk religion podcast
coming out
well at the beginning of january
hopefully will be the first episodes on
that uh in in terms of my other creative
projects i will be putting out some more
of the music that i make for this
channel so for those who don't know i
make most of the background music that
you hear in the videos most of that is
made by me
and i did release an ep last year with a
few of the tracks
there will be another actually full
album hopefully coming out pretty soon
with some of that
music that i have made
and i'll be generally also i'll be
trying to do some more music on my other
channel which is just called philly palm
so if you're interested in my musical
endeavors you can go and subscribe to
that and check out that channel
at least i want to
be a little more
active on that channel next year but
that does not mean i will be any less
active on this channel this will be my
main focus of course
although as i have done for the next
last six months or so i will be taking
it a little bit easier than i did last
year 2020 was pretty crazy i did
basically one video a week while also
working a full-time job on the side and
doing a bunch of other projects which at
the end of the day was not very very
good for my mental health so this last
year at least the second half of the
year i've been focusing a lot more on
giving myself some rest from time to
time some weeks i just took
the week off to
rest or to focus on doing research which
allows me to
make better content of course but also
to to recover and
refresh myself so which also leads to
better content hopefully and i'll be
continuing to to do that next year
my goal is to provide you with a couple
of videos a month but sometimes that
might not be possible
we'll see i won't have as strict of a
schedule as i had
like a year ago but there will be plenty
of content i have a long list of videos
that i want to do and
i'm really excited and inspired to keep
working
so anyway uh thank you all again so much
for the support for watching for
commenting for to my patrons thank you
so much um i'm really looking forward to
next year and to
see this community grow even more
again happy new year everyone and i hope
you have a wonderful 2022. i'll see you
in the next video
you